now Givens is with me chief executive of
tourism islands I'm going to lead an
organization that is both inside and
outside the EU at the same time you're
that rare person who straddles both
sides of the borders how do you engage
opinions on either side well we're an
organization that was set up under the
Good Friday Agreement to market the
island of Ireland north and south as a
destination abroad and it's been an
amazing successful venture so far in the
last five years we've seen a 50 percent
increase in business both north and
south and we've seen more jobs created
in tourism than any other industry and I
think as we look forward I mean we don't
know really what the future of bread is
gonna look like but what's very hard
thing is that all political parties are
saying that the common travel area must
remain I mean the island of Ireland from
a tourism perspective has done very well
and I think from a tourism perspective
people won't make decisions on the
holidays based on politics they're gonna
come because they enjoy the destination
how many people who visit go to both
sides of the border I mean do people
routinely come to Dublin and Belfast and
mantra very much a growing side of the
business we had over 10 million visits
last year from abroad which is
significant given those about six and a
half million people live on the island
we've seen you know the business up by
over ten percent last year and we look
at business around Europe last year that
was up only about 2 percent so countries
like Spain Portugal Ireland Scandinavia
really benefitting as well from the safe
and secure perception which is great
used for Northern Ireland by the way you
know which is experienced and the major
tourism Renaissance over the last number
of years
for example Titanic Belfast which didn't
exist five years ago has seen a 30%
increase in business this year I was
voted by consumers as the world's
leading tourism attraction so a lot of
good things to shout about but you've
got effectively political stasis now in
Northern Ireland and clearly breakfast
is going to have an impact what
contingency plans are you making well
we've got very closely at both
jurisdictions but I mean above all we're
marketing out there to the consumers to
come to Ireland because the friendliest
ones are the people the scenery the
culture I was seeing great results
businesses up again during the course of
2017 I mean obviously the most immediate
impact is going to be currency which
affects the Republic of Ireland that
doesn't impact Northern Ireland into the
future there have been some great
initiatives between the UK and Ireland
for example the British Irish visa
Scheme which means tourists coming from
China and India now can go to the UK in
Ireland as if it was one country we're
very keen to see that type of
collaboration between the UK and
and continue whatever but the future of
Briggs it looks like but what if I mean
and it could happen even if people don't
wanted to what if you ended up with a
hard border where you have to show your
passport to go from one to the other
what impact would that have and what you
do well I think you know from a tourism
perspective it's almost an impossibility
I always use the statistics statistic
that shows that over 60 percent of North
American and mainland European business
to Northern Ireland comes via the
Republic of Ireland so it's
inconceivable that we could really
operate with the border of menteur is in
perspective so I'd be fairly confident
given all the statements that have been
made by all the parties across the whole
of the UK in Ireland that really the
common travel area is something that
must remain thank you very much okay now
Givens a chief executive of tourism
Ireland